I was embarrassed because of what I
forgot I forgot the strength of a woman
I watched that little girl come out of
her mom's body I was like yeah
women are powerful you know and now
here's where I made my mistake
I'm not expecting this to be some
seasoned veteran vagina you know what I
mean I don't know what I'm doing this
thing hasn't gone through pregnancies
and periods and yeast infections and all
this you poor ladies got to go
through I thought this thing was a a new
Desert Rose
I thought we had to be soft
and gentle my daughter's water boarding
it for 20 minutes under the
faucet
and I don't care one man in here is oh
whatever you give me your ball back give
me the most seasoned veteran ball bag in
this building night and we put under
that water pressure I saw and your ball
starts spinning like this you'll be like
oh wow
[Music]
oh please I'll tell you all my secrets
oh God